There is no such thing
as a global anthem,
a global currency,
or a global flag.
This is the United States of America
that I'm representing.
I'm not representing the globe.
I am representing
your country.
Donald Trump has promised
to make America great again
by putting America first.
Though he was speaking at the
Conservative Political Action Conference,
or CPAC,
it's gotta be said that
he is no small-government conservative.
In fact, his speech made clear
that he represents the worst tendencies
of conservative Republicans and liberal Democrats
to limit our freedoms in the name
of supposedly serving the greater good.
Trump is an economic protectionist
and interventionist,
who wants to promote what he perceives
are "our values."
by building a wall to keep out immigrants,
charging tariffs on imports,
badgering US companies to stay here,
and making pipelines with only American steel.
All of that will only make everything cost more
while reducing employment.
The GOP
will be
from now on
the party,
also,
of the American worker.
He talks about bringing back manufacturing jobs,
but they peaked as a
percentage of the workforce in 1943
and are never coming back
for a very good reason.
Thanks to technological innovation,
manufacturing output has doubled since the 1980s
but with 1/3rd fewer workers.
Shutting down free trade
or playing CEO-in-chief is not going to change that.
At the heart of Trump's confusion
is his belief that putting America First
means keeping the world at a distance.
But you can be a citizen of America
and a citizen of the world.
In fact, if you believe in political, economic,
and cultural freedom,
you must always hold such dual citizenship.
There's no more basic freedom than the right to live
where you want and buy what you want.
That's not anti-America.
That is America.
In different ways over the years,
Republicans and Democrats have tried to control
where we can live, who we can marry,
what we can eat, drink, and smoke, and so much more.
Trump represents not a release from such thinking
but a shotgun marriage
of that worst impulse in each party.
We're going to win,
we're going to win big folks,
we're going to start winning again, believe me.
We're going to win.
"Where liberty dwells, there is my country,"
Ben Franklin is said to have written.
In putting America First,
Donald Trump will succeed
only in leaving even more of us truly homeless.